hey there and welcome to pro flows
number 42 I'm Cameron and and this one
I'm going to show you how to do some
really easy depth of field with 3d
layers inside of After Effects so I've
got a composition set up here it's a 3d
layer you can see the check box is on
right here and here it is in our main
composition and down here below I have
another view set up which is my top view
you can see right here and if you don't
have a set that you can just set it down
here at the at the very bottom so it's
the top and here's our layer and here's
our layer okay so I've got two viewers
just so it's easier to see what's going
on here so the first I'm gonna do is I
want to scale this puppy down some
pretty large layer so we'll go down to
about 30% here you can see at the top
view here's our main view and let's
duplicate let's actually call this
foreground layer let's duplicate it and
let's call this background and for the
background layer let's bring to the
bottom of stacking order hit P for
position and let's just take it back in
z space 400 pixels so you can see as I'm
doing that you can't see the difference
here but you can see on the top view
here it is so I'm selecting it bring it
over here to the right so I can my
foreground bring it over here to the
left so we've got two layers here in our
composition our main composition and
they're 3d layers and they look like
there are about on the same plane but
one that looks slightly smaller when an
actuality one is just pushed farther
back in z space so I'm gonna go to layer
new camera and and here's our camera and
I'm gonna select a 28 millimeter and
abled up to focus click OK there we go
so not much has changed here in our main
viewpoint viewport but you can see
here's our camera ok now if I open up
the camera here and I open up camera
controls and I can see depth of field is
on so if I look at my top view this is
an easy way for me to tell what's going
to be in focus in my main composition
so I'm gonna bring my cursor here in my
timeline to one second I'm going to set
a keyframe for focus distance I'm going
to go to two seconds and I'm going to
bring back this focus distance to this
background layer so that it's in focus
at this point so I'm going to drag it
right there and boom we're now in focus
here now
this background layer is now in focus
the foreground layer is out of focus but
it doesn't look like that's the case
even though depth of field is on the
trick here is to crank up your aperture
so we're set to fourteen point one seven
three two that's the preset for 28
millimeters if I start dragging this up
watch my layers watch what happens you
can see the foreground starting to go
out of focus the background staying in
focus I'm going to crank it way up here
something like 1200 pixels and that
looks pretty good I can also increase
the blur level here just a tad to give
it a little bit more depth of field now
if I go back to my focus distance at one
second the foregrounds InFocus the
backgrounds out of focus now one more
quick tip here is to change your Irish
shape from fast rectangle this is the
default inside of After Effects change
it to one of these presets down here to
get a little bit nicer depth of field
blur the octagon or any of these presets
are going to take a little bit longer to
render than fast rectangle but they do
look nicer and there you go there's our
simple rack focus depth of field effect
inside of After Effects